huh uh subscribe thank you so much for
having me um
CID it's a great feeling
um tonight I want to talk about
something that I'm really passionate
about and something that's very real to
me and this has been not a quality I'd
say it is more of a journey and before I
give you some pointers I would at least
would like you to take you around this
journey and help you understand the from
the use cases and how uh I've worked on
this problem and how you can also maybe
do some from your own home
okay now uh so tonight I'll talk about
three letters uh which I felt were
pretty commonplace but it turns out that
they are not and these three letters are
ISL which stand for Indian sign language
it's both people uh in India who are
different and who don't have the ability
to communicate so I will do something
always something for them and this is my
my choice so let's get started
from the slides
uh something on myself I just graduated
from Carnegie University I am currently
working at Yahoo I have invited by
Google to within my work on sign
language which I will talk about uh in
more details in a couple of minutes uh I
have my tutorial accepted that IEEE
conference
um interview Division I have involved
that Intel job innovator award in 2019
delegate at 2020 Harvard College
conference and I've learned a lot of
multiple sessions on machine learning
uni so
um I'm hoping that you guys are in good
hands
uh but before we go because of the
journey I want to talk about myself in a
few slides so that you guys get an
understanding of where I come from the
things that I really like uh so this is
me in my bachelor this is a college in
Pune this is me uh playing the guitar
and my friend who's singing is part of
our cultural phase that happens every
year then I started working as a data
science engineer at Lowe's Technologies
we used to make search and learning
applications for
the Lowe's Home Improvement website this
is me from the team then I came to CMU
ASP studying at started my college at
animal University
um and then finally I am doing a work in
recommendations so I recently got my uh
poster published at Yahoo market so I'm
really happy about that
on it so now that we have the the
background set now you guys know what we
guys probably relate a bit more to me
um I want to talk about my motivation
and this motivation comes from a video
that I saw in 2018 uh it's about a
person whose name is Tanya from Lisa and
she had no motor uh motion from her neck
down so she'll basically paralyze her
neck down and this is her journey
um it's gonna be a short video around
two minutes which explains how she used
her
skills to help who will use Morse code
in their own whole keyboard so let's
have a look at the video and I hope you
guys take something uh towards the end
of this week
this
is Morse code by pudding dots and dashes
with switches melted near my hand as a
very young child I used a communication
word board I use the head stick to point
to the words it was very attractive to
say the least
once Morse code was incorporated into my
life it was a feeling of pure Liberation
and freedom
[Music]
I think that is why I like skydiving so
much it is the same kind of feeling
through skydiving I met can the love of
my life and partner in crime
it's always been very very difficult
just to find a morse code devices to try
Morse code this is why I had to create
my own
I have a voice and more Independence in
my daily life but most people don't have
kin
it is our hope that we can collaborate
with the gboard team to help people who
want to tap into the freedom of using
Morse code she boards is the Google
keyboard what we have discovered working
on keyboard is that there are entire
pockets of population in the world in
Westing buckets it's like tens of
millions of people who have never had
access to a keyboard that works in their
own language with Tanya we've built
support in g-forward for morse code so
it's an input modality that allows you
to type in Morse code and get text out
with predictions suggestions I think
it's a beautiful example of word machine
learning can really assist someone in a
way that a normal keyboard without
artificial intelligence wouldn't be able
to I am very excited to continue on this
journey many many people will benefit
from this and that thrill to me to no
end
[Music]
thank you
um all right thank you so much for
watching that video and this video
served an important motivation point for
me uh this I watched this video back in
2018 this is part of their Google I O uh
Summit that happens
um and then that's when I realized okay
it's important to find problems in your
community and help find and solve it
technology and that's when I realized
that through potential of technology and
how we'll be using it
okay uh let's talk about
let's talk about Islam Indian sign
language uh recognition but before we do
that let's talk about it in sign
language
so uh based on the statistics around 18
million people in India have speech and
hearing Implement which is around one
person of the population less than one
person
uh since India is a diverse country
there are different languages different
dialects different people
um their sign language also changes and
this is something that I realized uh
finally working on this project that is
sign language within India is not
Universal
um and that makes it much more difficult
for a system to incorporate everything
and finally sign language is not an
official language it is still still
considered as a skill in India and when
something is not an official language
the
government is not entitled to what does
not really have to give it means to make
sure that people feel uh included
now based on uh data from 2020 18 only
to 50 certified sign language
interpreters exist in India although I
am assuming that is numbers going to be
more uh but because the actual certified
uh interpreters
and then based on a survey only 30
percent of specially even people are
able to receive help in India and there
is something that I find uh pretty
interesting in the US that there's
always room for accessibility room for
inclusion and one of the reasons why I
was enamored by by us was when I came to
Pittsburgh I saw all these road signs
all these uh all my University lecture
Falls had very had inclusive inclusivity
so that people from who are not uh how
especially able can also feel inclusive
all right so let's talk about sign
language and what I wanted to do
um so I wanted to develop my sign
language technician system that used AI
to generalize sign language across
population so for example if you move
across different uh areas in India at
least it should be able to get certain
nuances and understand that and help
solve them and then I also want to keep
the resource to awareness uh we don't
want to depend on gpus or expensive
Hardware want to develop this so only on
CPU and family deployed on on mobile
phones which can be easily accessed
now the methodology that I follow and
this is true for any sign language is
you can classify that in three
categories so the first if you are able
to get the hand issue respect sign
language is all about hand gestures if
you're able to correctly identify them
and maybe
um
classify them you can get what the sign
means also facial expressions then
Embrace what role uh there are different
data expression could mean different
things in sign language
and then finally code estimation this uh
would make it like completely stick but
even if you get the first two you can
solve around 19 to 95 percent of the
problems inside manual engineering
all right so the journey that I thought
that I will see is I thought that I will
just go to nmg to fill the model and
then probably build the production but
that's not what happened
for the first six months I just spent
learning sign language learning
interacting with the people
understanding the problem that they have
and how people are helping or how the
daily channels that they are facing
then I formulated account statement uh I
went okay I was I broke the problem into
different pieces and tried to install
each one at a time and then I had to go
back iterate and get feedback uh based
on my interaction with the NGO with the
teachers uh then get expert feedback
um luckily I was lucky enough to have
good connections all over the world I
talked to a professor here at in NYC
um where you you mentioned that ASL or
American sign language is universal
throughout the US so even if you go from
California to New York Michigan Ohio
sign language that makes it easier for
some something to be built scalably but
in India that's not the case
um
and then uh I once the solution uh was
there I verified it gave it back to the
sign language stability in India and
asked um for help and wanted to
understand if my problem if my solution
is good enough for the problem or not
and then finally if you got that
requesting so that it can be used by by
people uh in India
they help me understand different signs
for different alphabets different uh
simple gestures uh just so that I can
build my application details
um so I decided to divide my application
into different versions of different
phases uh so the first case was the
easier easiest one I just wanted to see
if I could actually develop something
like this or not so for the first phase
um I just went with the hand gestures so
here you can see these are different
hand gestures for different digits
um and then I moved on to different
alphabets so from one hand in version
one we had digits were mostly in one
hand
um and then alphabet they used two hands
and as you can see I am using image
processing techniques to just work with
a skeletal image and all the actual
image so I'm reducing noise and making
sure that my algorithm can be
um
flexible and lightweight so that it can
it can work on on different phones and
as devices
so there's a source in a bit of how it
works so I use a small trick um I am
wearing blue colored gloves which and
then doing color segmentation on it uh
and on the right you can see that I'm
not working with the entire image just
working uh with just my hand gesture so
this makes the image lightweight um and
it helps me only work on on the part of
the image that actually has the option
so that this this made my algorithm fast
not the best way of doing it but I just
wanted to see if I could do something
like this in a short span of time
then I move to version two one two
um which you guys remember uh talks
about facial expressions
um so I had a
um I had a different model that used to
capture facial key points so I'm
tracking
um different key points
um let me let's look at the video so in
this video you can see that I'm tracking
my eyes my nose uh my lips the jaw and
again my hands uh and then there's a
bounding box around it just to make sure
that all the the data that I'm working
with is just the uh the subject that I'm
looking at I'm not the entire
um and this help again helped me uh not
only keep my model like it but also the
noise from the background can
sufficiently corrupt the model if your
model is not a well trained so I just
try to do that and I think it will work
well and giving answers or gestures in
real time so right now Volume 2 is still
only static gestures so as you can see
I'm using each frame and then running an
algorithm and getting each
production across each
um this may not be the best way of doing
it uh but it was good enough for me to
get started
okay uh let's talk about two point one
then I thought yeah I'll add voice to it
so
I use a simple Google text to speech
hi so basically for injector it gives
you some sort of uh understand audio
feedback
very minor adjustment
but then with version three then I try
to combine different uh parts of
different frames so I took a screenshot
of 10 seconds worth of sign language uh
that's was a static number so for 10
seconds my algorithm is going to analyze
all the frames and then give a gives a
meaningful answer so let's just have a
look at this particular video
so these include just some of the basic
uh phrases that people might use for
example I'm not feeling well as a doctor
and things like that so I'll experiment
experiment with around 20-25 different
uh simple gestures and then the results
are pretty positive
where in case of uh in case of normal
words how we communicate is that right
now we are having a communication like
I'm able to speak because you can get a
sense of what I'm talking throughout the
entire sentence and maybe
it will throw them in the battle but the
algorithm that I developed mostly took
static images of static data and then
try to predict on each frame but then
ideal ideal wave should have been to use
maybe a sequential model where you are
passing context from the first thing for
the frames as well and then forming the
entire sentence or the entire paragraph
and not just two or three words at a
time
could be solved
and I was lucky enough I will not play
this video but you can have a look I was
lucky enough to be invited to
um to Google in California in 2019 I was
in India at that time and there was a
spawn control happened for the expert
group uh in Google in India as part of
that and I got a chance to come here and
remember the video that we just saw
about time animation that was my
motivation and then after this
conference uh I think I got some good
reviews uh Google decided to actually do
a video on the journey that I I followed
um so I'm just going to clear that it's
again two and a half or three minutes
have a look at that and
um
[Music]
I come from a small family currently
staying in Mumbai my father and my
brother are in working in finance
department and they wanted me to do the
same but I always believe that my
passion is coding
you
huge and family what happens your father
is considered to be the real boss but in
actuality the mother is the real head of
the family so once my mother is
convinced convincing my father is pretty
easy for my mother
when I joined University and I wanted to
explore as a person who I was so I did a
lot of things other than computer
science and in 2018 I saw a video by
Tanya affiliation at Google I O she held
Google's keyboard team to integrate more
support into the Google keyboard and
that is something that really inspired
me to affect people in a positive way
after graduation I started auditing at a
deaf Animal Institute near my place
after five to six months of spending
time in learning sign language I was
still having problems communicating with
them effectively that's when I realized
that somebody who does not know sign
language will have a lot of problems
communicating with a definite person I
wanted to use tensorflow and machine
learning to get the images in real time
from the camera and then translate them
to speech so basically it was gesture to
speech
foreign
images
I showed this initiative to my friends
and they are pretty excited and they
ended up spending a lot of time with me
on telekina data set
so I use Vision API to make my images a
bit more clean but again after doing
that my machine learning model was not
performing up to the market this is when
I realized that when with using sign
language you don't have to only depend
on the gestures but your facial
expressions also play a very important
role me and my friends after this we
went and took thousands of photos with
both hand Jesus as well as facial
features
of course my friends were quite upset
with me but I think another Pizza really
kept their motivation
before is operating facial expressions
my machine learning model was just
predicting letters and numbers after
adding facial expressions I could
incorporate for much more wider gestures
like being scared of being confused or
if you understood something you could do
it very simply so this really help my
machine learning more appeal to a wider
problems
[Music]
solution for the communities in India I
believe that using the same technology
people all over the world could solve
issues for their own communities
[Music]
so much for watching that video
um
so I had a great time making this video
but apart from that I had a really fun
time spending around 18 to 24 months
where I used to work here at bngu
understand the problem and then help
build a simple solution for it
now comes the question how
now comes the question is how can you
help okay so the first and I'm working
one for inner likely is awareness to be
honest I was back in India I was not
aware of the issues that especially able
people feel every day in India so just
talking about something at least
addressing the issues Falls
I was not aware that timeline was such a
media problem in India and that sign
language was not Universal I thought
that it should be Universal and it
should be taught to students like how it
teach English or other languages but it
is not uh but having that awareness
helps us to move ahead and solve the
problem
second is you can find this petition you
can go to the my slides and there's a
link to a change.org petition which
petitions this sign language should be
made into an official language it's
currently a skill
volunteer uh I actually was at a low a
low point in my life when I started
working at lnu and it helped me recover
it helped me uh feel motivated it gave
me a purpose
um and also it's a it's a lot of fun
and finally you should learn the
language if you if you really feel a
passionate about it if you learn ASL or
ISL that doesn't matter at least have
some uh knowledge it really helps when
you communicate with people
um so yeah so that was almost it uh I
will talk a bit about my own interests
um so I am the kind of person who likes
to uh get different passions and mix
them together so I also play the guitar
you might have seen in one of the photos
so I use a simple hand tracking my hand
gesture recognition to use with my uh
with my
there's no
click right now but then you can
probably use this to help teach retire
to younger audiences then I also played
around with how we can use uh
into make your workouts more fun
then I also did something for for a game
called Cricket which is pretty popular
in India it's it's like American
football or soccer and uh but just for
the Indian audience
um and in like in any sport you need to
understand uh how uh your body flour so
there's like a simple algorithm that I
developed it's finally open so you can
have a look at that as well
uh and so yeah this is pretty much it uh
thank you so much for listening to me if
you guys have any questions or any
queries feel free to reach out to me
right now on my website or on LinkedIn
uh but before I go uh I just want to
give you something and the most
important words are in any language is
thank you so the next time you say thank
you to anyone you can simply sign for
the sign language for thank you is this
so next time you probably go to
um a restaurant or doing somebody who's
basically will
um you should let them know that they're
not alone
uh so thank you so much guys uh again
this is me uh this is the link to the
slides my name is that's my Twitter you
are a URL that's my website and then
that's my link so if you want to have a
look at every other link that I'm on you
can have a look at Liberty
and thank you so much for listening to
me you guys have been here
um now if you have any questions I would
love to take them
thank you
I'm just curious how you're going to
progress like from using the gloves and
service yeah segmentation to something
more tolerant yeah
um so if you if you see uh so this was
like an old experiment I did in 2018 my
sign language work uh so the videos are
from that area but if you look at
this particular video uh this one so
there's no gloves uh on my hands and I'm
still able to detect it correctly so now
this is a video that I recorded many
many one I feel like a couple of years
back so there are at more Advanced
Technologies
um but in 2018 there were less Advanced
Technologies less I had a cheaper
computer less resources but there is
something called as
um media pipe uh let's see the library
by Google and they have this amazing
capabilities where you can track and
just search you can track quality pose
estimations you can chat facial key
points as well so I'm planning to use
something like this
um so that I don't have to depend on the
glove
I hope that options away
well the translation is from Indian into
English it's from Indian to Indian
languages from Indian sign language to
Hindi so not English but a lot of the
words are the same so for different
English alphabets we sign language is
the same
okay
um
any other questions
no it's not currently bi-directional uh
but that's actually a pretty interesting
idea to have in bi-directionally it is
currently not uh but that's a good idea
I have to think about it thank you so
much
okay um sounds good thank you so much
guys uh thank you